so
our next speaker
is dr adelaide rhodes
so dr rhodes has more than 20 years of
experience in analyzing big data at the
molecular organismal and ecological
scale
she holds a phd in zoology for ncsu and
an ms in biotechnology and
bioinformatics from john hopkins
as a bioinformatic informatician and
strategic consultant she has assisted
dozens of universities and government
researchers to analyze cancer crop
science bacteria virus implant genomes
transcriptomes and these disease variant
data sets she has developed advanced
workflows for secondary and tertiary
analysis
and has written custom scripts in bash r
matlab and sas to interrogate large data
sets for meaningful signals
she also has a strong publication record
that spans multiple disciplines
recently she has helped researchers
develop pipelines for data-driven
discovery um such as hail gwas and cnn
using a variety of workflow languages
like wdl cwl and snake make and next
flow
on hpc and commercial cloud computing
resources like aws and gcp
she also provides consultation on ai and
ml genomic opportunities for data-driven
discovery in the health and life
sciences
so now i would like to turn it over to
dr adelaide rhodes
hi there um should i share my screen for
my powerpoint
yes please okay
yeah let me uh share screen
and
pull it up
i wasn't sure about the meeting format
so let me do that oh great can you guys
see my slide
yes we can okay good um this is going to
be a little different
and thank you alice for that
presentation i'll just say that i use
google cloud you might hear a little bit
of that
when i talk about what i've been doing
and um
yeah so
what is what i'm going to talk about
today is
well that that sounded really impressive
with laura laura i read out all those
like qualifications and what i do
but i didn't
just start out that way so my talk today
is a little bit of a motivational
speech about anybody
can get to where i am if you just put
your
time and effort into finding ways to
kind of
get involved and
improve your skill sets
so um
i do have to say that because i work for
an ng now like my the views and opinions
are only my views and opinions and
they're not a representation of any
organ organization to which i currently
belong or i have previously belonged
okay so i'm going to walk you guys
through my little a little bit of my
life story and then give you at the end
uh
talk about lessons learned so in order
to kind of give you guys a bigger
picture i'm just going to talk about
being a scientist
and then switching from being a
scientist to becoming a bioinformatics
faculty member
at a university and then
realizing that wasn't a fit and then
moving on to
working in bioinformatics full-time
mainly with cloud
content
and then of course we all kind of
experienced the pandemic so what does
that do to our careers how does that
look like and then is this an
opportunity not not something that hurt
us
okay
so
just to give you an idea of where i was
20 or so years ago i studied copa
crustations which are at the bottom of
the food chain in the oceans uh they're
very important species for fisheries
there's been seventy five thousand
described species and i spent most of my
time looking through a microscope at
these organisms and trying to describe
them
and then i later got into
dna barcoding that was my
gateway into bioinformatics because
i was generating a lot of sequences for
unique organisms
that were being collected here you can
see sherry reed and another oh that's me
down below in the lower right corner i
used to go out and collect benthic
species
sort them look at them under a
microscope but it would be really nice
to know if this had ever been observed
somewhere before so this was near the
beginning of the barcode of life project
um
so i contributed a lot of marine species
to that effort
basically 18s or co
coi uh
see um cytochrome oxidase one
sorry as species uh sequences so this
was actually back in the day like we're
running them in the lab how a singer
sequencer to put them together
and the frustrating thing was like i
would go onto the databases and i'd be
like
and no one's ever seen this before
and that pretty much happened for most
of the species i was working on i was
cataloging them to be of service but a
lot of them were unique observations
um and then this happened so i was
working in florida around the time the
deepwater horizon oil spill
and what's happening here is that we had
to collect a lot of data really quickly
so this kind of pushed the boundaries of
what was being done in our lab to
include a lot more thought about how to
collect a lot of data about a lot of
different species over several years
and um i be i was put in charge of not
the copepod crustaceans but the tenet
crustacean observations and you can see
here on a slide i had to look back in
time i wanted to know what had people
observed previously so i could
understand
what i was observing now once again just
validating whether there were new
species in this region or not so it did
involve data but it didn't involve any
genetic data
but i did want to do uh genomics because
we were working a very interesting and
unique environment the deep sea so deep
sea environments are really different um
not sure how much you guys know about it
but there are coral
species at the bottom of the ocean that
do not require
uh photosynthetic organisms oxantheli
to
live there's a lot of symbiotic
organisms things that
because it's very sparse there can be a
large distance between species
or little species islands you know
things have learned how to grow up
together so there's just a few pictures
here the pretty corals and the
um
the commensal species the brittle stars
that hang on the corals but there's so
many examples of that so it's a really
unknown environment and so getting a
really good
list of species that were at the
different sites was really important and
as you can imagine being very good at
organizing the data being able to access
the data you know tens of thousands of
observations plus observations on the
conditions the uh bio
chemical conditions at the bottom of the
ocean were important too because we were
kind of trying to build data layers like
looking at the species looking at the
chemistry
looking at physical conditions looking
at where the plume was flowing that all
it like
was very complicated
and it resulted in quite a few papers so
what i realized through this process and
where am i going with this is that i
really like the data part and so i did
get a chance to
do some uh more
bar coding type genomics
as a side project during this time so i
really really realized two things about
myself that the parts i liked about my
job
believe it or not as a marine biologist
did not involve going out to see
um they actually involved the part like
where we had a bunch of data and a lot
of spreadsheets and then we had to tell
a story we had to say this is what
happened here this is what we need to
pay attention to
so looking for patterns um
trying to come up with hypothesis and
then testing the hypothesis all on a
computer
it's fascinating stuff so that's when i
decided to make a career change and it
didn't happen overnight i did go back to
school even though i had a phd
i chose the johns hopkins university
program in biotech with a
major in bioinformatics because well
first of all it was one of the only two
that were available online 100 online at
that time the other one was stanford and
that stanford was double the price
and the other thing was the um for the
amount of time you had to invest it was
very comprehensive like you took
molecular biology
you took computer science classes and
all that so you have to understand my
phd was in biology
didn't mean that i knew how to do
bioinformatics so i really really
appreciated that program and so as a
result of getting a master's i actually
was able to get a professor job over at
oregon state university so that's what
the little bieber guy is there and so i
ended up moving over to oregon state and
the best way to learn is by teaching so
even though i was a very new
bioinformaticist i taught classes before
so i thought about um what do i want to
learn and then i started teaching things
i really wanted to learn about and i
taught them several times a year
to graduate students undergrads and then
other people like myself basically a lot
of people who came up through school
finished school before any of this
existed so i had to you know construct
classes i had to understand how to do
the data analysis so it was a great way
to learn how to to do more
um and so that's when i also realized
what is my favorite programming language
it's bash so i really do like bash and
it's just the cleanest and stuff but i
did uh you know have to know r and
python so being in a school teaching
volunteer teaching mentoring
for those of you out there who feel a
little bit of the imposter syndrome it
really helps you get past that because
you're transmitting you know you may
only be a couple steps ahead of somebody
but you're you are a couple steps ahead
of somebody so by transmitting that
information and getting involved in
projects i was able to kind of overcome
that
and then the other thing that i got to
do which was really fun and if you
notice at the beginning the little guy
holding up the sign as a beaver that was
the mascot of the school so i was
actually put in charge of a really cool
opportunity to teach students through
generating hands-on
experience with a genome assembly
project and of course we picked the
beaver to do the genome assembly which
meant that uh the students and other
professors that were working on the
project we were all involved from the
very beginning to the very end data
collection data analysis
um what did we learn from having another
rodent genome because of course mice and
rats are fundamental organisms for
medical research but there isn't a lot
of diversity out there at that time for
other genomes that you could look at for
other answers and so there's a few
features of the bieber that aren't
present in other rodents
such as the castor
sac they make a castor oil and the fact
that they live most of their lives in
dens in the water so they do have to be
able to hold their breath
um a very long time and another feature
about beavers is that they are ecosystem
engineers so their brains may develop
differently so i was in charge mainly
with the transcriptomic part and then
cataloging um we didn't really find any
new genes right you know we just found
homologs but um there were long
non-coding rnas that were very
interesting that might have shown how
beavers evolved over time to take
advantage of the
environment they lived in
and so that resulted in this paper about
pan tissue transcriminal
transcriptomic atlas methods to find
lung non-coding rna so this is the first
paper where we actually built a new
pipeline something that hadn't been done
before in order to quickly steam
screen for um long non-coding rnas in
non-model organisms
um so just think about the fact that
like if you haven't had a lot of chances
to get involved or learn
um this is an opportunity like maybe on
your own campuses at your companies like
there's always a way to get more
experience so uh volunteering or finding
uh opportunities to help other people do
their projects is a great way um
so
you know i i
my job was in the core facility for
those of you who don't know what a core
facility is it's basically a service
that is provided by the university so
anybody studying anything can come into
your office and ask for help and the
university subsidizes the salaries and
the supplies for people in
the uh facility so i'm just going to
flip through a few different examples
and so these were not research projects
i initiated these were ones where people
came into our facility asked for help
and it was my job to try to get them the
best answers i could so we looked at
viruses and oh my seats which are slime
molds
um oops sorry uh
another project i got involved in with
molly burke's off uh lab was a molecular
yeast evolution pipeline
um upgrade so that was an automation
project i also was co-author in a paper
about canine human bladder cancer
comparisons that was very interesting
because we not only got to
do a deep dive into canine
cancer we actually looked at human
cancer and combined data sets so that
was really comprehensive
study that was very challenging so i
learned a lot from that and also got
into a little bit of the modeling
and another one was looking at
pathogen molecular patterns so basically
um nate immunity in bugs so i did more
than one of those um stink bug was a a
more well
uh
publicized paper that i was on but they
were like as you can see there's like a
dozen
couple dozen people on the paper
so
you can get involved you can publish um
you don't always have to be the person
initiating the idea like if you're
willing to pitch in and look for unique
patterns or you're asked to because it's
your job you could certainly do research
and then i did continue my own research
looking at copepods and so i was using
reduced genome methods to be rad to try
to find biomarkers at a time when
on the right of the screen here you'll
see like a little map with pins in it
that's the coast of oregon and
california
and what's happening is there's a warm
waterfront that appears every few years
called the blob they really do call it
the blob and so the idea there was well
if there's this large patch of warmer
water could copepods from southern
regions be migrating into oregon and
sticking around
who cares like right but copepods are
the main food of salmon
so if they're
not recognizing the species of copepods
that have come into it to the area
because of the warm water are they going
to
have problems maintaining their body
weight and living through their maturity
because salmon come from rivers in
oregon and california and they go out to
the ocean and they live in the ocean for
a few years and then they need to have
all this energy stored up so they can
make it back into the rivers in order to
um
uh
you know be able to spawn and pass on
their genetics to
other other salmon so it was a really uh
interesting project still went out to
see a little bit
um and generate some novel data that
kind of showed that yes there were some
stratifications in the populations that
hadn't been seen ever uh
you know before and that was enabled by
genetics genomics and big data oh and
this i just throw this picture in here
because we were also having the
pyrosomes there were like a million
things called sea pickles so we'd throw
out our nets and we'd pull them in and
instead of getting a bunch of fish and
flounder and stuff just fyi we got these
things called um sea pickles and they
were a big deal that year and that had a
lot to do with global
climate change right because this warm
water area other species were coming in
and taking advantage of it so i could
have been happily content to work on
other people's projects
and everything but i had also been
getting really fascinated with cloud
computing and using um cloud to answer
questions so this was about seven years
ago i mean now we all use cloud and
cloud is accessible we just had a
presentation talking about cloud but i
really really wanted to go in that
direction with my career
for some reason so i ended up moving to
boston and my first job actually did
involve google cloud platform called
terra if you're not familiar it's at the
broad institute and the idea of a terra
is that it brings together all the
resources you need to reproduce a study
so you may know the pain of reading a
paper a very interesting paper and
you're like oh man i could totally use
that idea and then you start reading
through the methods and it says produced
by custom scripts
you know that are you know and then
you'll call the lab and they'll be like
oh yeah those custom perl scripts you
know disappeared when our grad student
left the lab we have no idea how they
actually did the analysis right or
there's a data set there's like a
spreadsheet and you know it's maybe just
one of the pieces of metadata that was
used to generate the um
the
final product but it's a very important
part but that's not in the supplementary
materials you can't find it again and
then you call the lab and they're like
we don't know that was like on a book
drive and then we had a fire and then we
don't have that anymore right that
happens all the time that's why cloud is
so important um because it put it gives
you a place to put all your stuff and
tara's cool because you can put together
your data sets you can put together your
methods and then you can actually run
really high throughput workflows uh
using things like the workflow
development language or cwl so you you
can use your free credits uh like i
heard
the person before me i was just talking
about that you can use your free credits
to play around with tara it's mainly
biomedical research but there's a lot of
really cool interesting stuff on there
and you can read it for free like you
don't actually even have to
sign in to get a lot of value out of it
because you can flip through the pages
and see how other people did the program
or how someone wrote their whittle or or
you can find doctors like you might need
a doctor for tidy verse or something
right like people have written that like
over and over again so that kind of
stuff's available in terra
oh thank you for putting the link
there laura it's tear it up bio but
anyway i don't work there anymore i um
i i really did enjoy my time there um
but i really wanted to not uh be stuck
in one one type of role i as a scientist
i kind of wanted to explore and do more
diverse things but um i'm also
just putting this up here this was one
of the products out of my work at tara
was
like a synthetic bam generator but you
can see here this arrow if you are not
familiar with the fair principles of
data science i really feel like it's
worth reading up about because there's
lots of opportunities so once again if
you're starting out and you're not quite
clear which direction ahead of your
career but you do want to make a
contribution
fair is a way to kind of get involved
and
know like how to present yourself how to
present your data how to make things
reproducible because if people can find
your stuff and use it very easily and
reproduce your research they're more
likely to cite you so if you're even if
you're still on the science track just
thinking a little bit about a project
before you start it is going to help you
and so i i just gave a talk to my
co-workers today about being fair so it
just means findable accessible
interoperable reusable
all right
don't don't make a spreadsheet and then
don't put it in supplementary in your
papers in other words and and um
but data was getting bigger and like i
said i wanted to get more challenge out
of my work so i went to
a third party cos a third party partner
for google cloud so i actually trained
people so i wanted to get beyond just
doing a thing and so once again i wanted
to learn how to do it better and for me
my philosophy if i teach somebody how to
do it i can i can learn how to do it
better myself so i'm very fascinated
this happens to be a google schematic
but there's aws corollaries there's also
you know azure i'm not trying to
influence any kind of product decisions
but basically you can build up from i
know how to use a spreadsheet to okay so
i can take that spreadsheet and put it
into a database so now i know how to use
bigquery and i know bigquery oh wow
that's going to enable me to ask
interesting research questions through
machine learning and then well maybe i
need a model for this thing i'm trying
to do i'll go over to the google brain
and look for some advanced protocols
right so
i like the versatility and the flow of
google so i tend to default there but
like i said there's
really great choices on all the cloud
providers
and this is just an example kind of a
product that i came out with
showing the power of cloud because we
are generating genomes at a faster rate
than anybody ever anticipated
and even just knowing where to put them
is a challenge so cloud it's all about
like how do i store a large amount of
data how do i access that data and then
what can i say about the data um after
you know everybody else has done all
this really important work putting the
data where we can get to it
um what can i do with it so those are
the kinds of questions you should ask
yourself
as you're going through your career like
what what parts do you like where do you
want to be
um
and then like i really got into
kubernetes kubernetes the next flow and
all that through those experiences
and uh one thing i found i lacked in and
i went back and got some more training
through coursera et cetera was how to
present the data back to the researcher
so i spent a lot of time thinking about
these interactive tools such as are
shiny
or plotly
or observable right there's there's a
million of them popping up now because
that is a common need you could be
somebody who specializes in that like if
you particularly don't like any of the
database stuff or you don't particularly
care about the infrastructure
just knowing how to communicate is so
valid and and and these types of things
are very easy to learn and there's tons
of free documentation out there coursera
udemy
github itself like people put up very
nice and uh web pages and share like how
how to build these like visualization
and interactive tools and then um that
resulted in me like doing some work
where
you can find these videos out there on
the internet if you care about but like
trying to fill in those gaps like i'd be
like man nobody knows how
like
the ncbi is on the cloud right like
everyone keeps hearing that ncbi is on
the cloud but like how do you actually
like go to the cloud get the data and
use it for something that's the gap
that's the cap that i keep trying to
fill that like yes it's on the cloud
cloud is great but if you can't
have a concept of even what that means
you're not even going to be able to take
advantage of all these cool freely
available free resources because even
though um you know google and amazon and
azure cost money they all have free
tiers and i heard a little discussion
about credits there's ways to get
credits like you sign up for google you
get like 300 right away you know there's
ways to
kind of dip your toe in the water
without spending any money
at all
but getting the benefit of of
thousands of researchers data and so
i've seen this a lot with the pandemic
data like a lot of that was made
publicly available
and other um
there was a kid here like his high
school project was making a dashboard
for the data that just kind of updated
people and it got a lot of buzz it was
really popular and then now he just went
out and made a dashboard for ukrainian
refugees like people who want to share
their houses connecting them because
this data exists it
there's just a gap like how do i get to
it how do i find it how do i use it so
that's a really good opportunity
and then as i mentioned there was a
pandemic i didn't build a dashboard but
i did other things i'm i spent a lot of
time like on uh trying to develop skill
sets through hackathons
and by volunteering once again to teach
through the bioinformatic virtual
coordination network which has a bunch
of free lessons like an rna-seq
metagenomics genome assembly
you know
gene annotation things like that
all right um oh this is my last slide so
just a little
thought about the different categories
of bioinformatics as you can see it's a
really diverse world
not everyone's going to be like me
whether you have a short attention span
and you're going to jump from one to the
other to the other right um but that's
my style that's who who i am so i would
say to you guys
be who you are
figure out which part you like
invest time in yourself always be
building your skill sets like i said you
don't have to spend a lot of money
there's so many free things out there
networking this group is great there's
always so many cool
opportunities on the linkedin coming out
of the group that is sponsoring the
symposium
um reaching out to people like a little
further ahead like two steps ahead of
you because like i said
i'm never
um
you know like put off by somebody asking
me for help because i'm always like oh
that's a great opportunity for me to
learn this thing better because now i'm
going to have to explain it to somebody
how you do this thing right so think of
it that way if you're shy or you're
afraid of asking for help on a
particular project
um but yeah that's about it that's all i
had to say this is me this is who i am
and i guess i have a few minutes to get
some questions and i i didn't okay here
we go
um
let's see i i did see that sona said
that you do diversity and ecology
jellyfish so hi sona
um
yes and then
it's not me i'm sorry it was uh i posted
it on behalf of uh jizzly uh oh thank
you thank you because i i think he
didn't have or um oh thank you thank you
very much for posting that
i must say now that i'm on online i know
this is out of my turn but uh extremely
inspiring talk amazing talk thank you
thanks
yeah and then i there's one here
question one how do you compare working
for academia versus working for the
industry that's a great question
um
i
i'm an impatient person so sometimes for
me in academia things didn't move fast
enough
but i also
don't have all the energy i used to when
i was younger so the problem is with
industry sometimes it moves a little too
fast so i'm looking for the goldilocks
job all the time where it's not too slow
but it's not too fast um in
academia the resources are limited but
that means your creativity gets an
opportunity to do the work that's why i
know about so many free things because
as an academic i had very little money
so you know i had to accomplish big
ambitions with with nothing
um
so i hope that answers that question
question two how do you decide what
kinds of research projects to focus on
to advance your career that's a great
question too and because
i'm the type of person who says do what
you love
i also like to love what i do so my
career decisions a lot of times have
been led by i just don't love this
anymore this is not something i see
myself doing like for 20 years and so
then i'll just go to the next level um
but that's not very practical for those
of you who
uh you know may not have the ability to
move around like i can so i would just
say
look for opportunities in your company
there's always somebody who needs like a
hand or help and you never know just
like by volunteering a little spending
that extra hour
with a project per week you know showing
up for a meeting that you weren't
necessarily invited to but you heard
about and got permission to attend those
are ways to kind of edge yourself over
you don't have to make leaps like i do
you can just edge yourself over
um and then of course taking the
trainings online are very helpful
because then you show up and you're now
the expert like maybe in your group
because you spend a little bit of extra
time on coursera or in the uh
pine bio you know platform learning how
to do a workflow and it's needed all the
time like other people just don't have
the time to look but if you have a
little bit of time to look
invest in yourself um i've only got two
minutes left but um question three how
has biofilm exchange over the past
decade it's just gotten bigger and
harder in the fact of um
you know storing data but it's gotten
more interesting and
impactful because you don't have to
collect the data to be the person to say
something about the data so that's
pretty cool um
let's see
sorry i'm going to expect manure says
i'm student of biochemistry i love to
learn more and more about bioinformatics
and genomics
yes people you please feel free to reach
out to me through linkedin i'm not
sharing my email because i don't check
my email enough to be a great person but
linkedin i see it pretty regularly so uh
do that
and
and then last question from elias is
what is a major skill student struggle
with on their path to mastering
bioinformatics i think it's confidence i
don't think it's even a skill i think
it's just believing that you are
so a lot of these changes i made was um
me saying uh i am that now i am a
bioinformaticist or i am a data
scientist
nobody made waved a magic wand over my
head and made me that like so that's why
i'm saying that students struggle with
that so just be the be the thing that
you think you are and you are so and
then the bvcn is just a freely available
set of lessons on github
it's called the bioinformatic virtual
coordination network i do link to it in
my linkedin profile you can see it in
the featured pages there like there's
links and there are videos and basic
lessons
it's all free it's all freely available
um just how to do metagenomics it's
mainly metagenomics but there is some
transcriptomics but for beginner
bioformatives it's a nice little set of
lessons that we wrote